as certain as we can be there's a very
large Chinese surveillance and
intelligence gathering program and a
very increasingly Global Chinese
military they're looking at basing I
mean even an Equatorial Guinea on the
Atlantic coast of Africa a year or so
ago not to mention the Middle East East
Africa Indian Ocean South Pacific
Chinese fishing vessels which are pretty
large when they're especially when
they're guarded by Maritime militia
we're operating aggressively off the
Galapagos recently so I think without
question we're going to all be feeling
uh the the sort of pressure from greater
Chinese intelligence and ultimately
military operations going forward